Yeah.
Books we read to our young children.
Well,
it depends on how young,
really young.
There's this book called how to teach your child to read in a hundred easy
lessons,
all type that.
Um,
yeah,
no,
I've done something technical.
It's called how to teach.
I mean,
something technically poor your child to read in 100 easy lessons.
That is an excellent book because you can actually teach your child to read in a
hundred easy lessons.
Very smart,
very,
very smart book.
Very well developed psychologically older kids.
I really liked the Harry Potter books.
I think that rolling nailed the mythological structure.
Um,
what else?
I mean,
I'm in collaboration with my daughter.
I'm putting together a reading list for young people for,
for kids and young adults.
So I guess I'll have to answer it that way.
MMM.
I can't bring it to mind and I can't bring it to mind.